trekking through this wee River Forest
Preserve in Ghana is tough going but
these conservationists are on a mission
researcher Gilbert Adam is here with
some American colleagues and a quest to
find a particular species of frog which
he first discovered a few years ago not
this one but the giant sweeper frog it's
not there only about thirty of them left
the same genus but another a trollop is
a different one by a forest one is a
good finds a great fine we spend
sometimes a whole week or two weeks
every month here looking for it
for instance we started from June and it
was not on so the beginning of this
month so it took four months and then we
found one here
Gilbert Adam has devoted his career to
the giant squeeker frog more often than
the frogs though he finds deep pits left
by illegal gold prospectors anyway for
the tree frogs they can also come out
that because they will eat just like
this or they were struggle and if
there's a predator there the pro cannot
be able to escape
the frogs natural habitat is also
threatened by logging Gilbert Adam shows
his colleagues from the US NGO saved the
frogs the damage that's been wreaked by
the timber industry loggers are allowed
to fell just three trees per hectare
here but in fact they chopped down a lot
more leaving devastated landscapes in
their wake there's been a war for us we
cannot fight them what we have been
doing is to educate the local people
that this forest is not for any timber
company it's not for the government it's
for didn't look out people the village
of York Rome is located on the edge of
the reserve
if the Sui Forest and the frogs that
live in it are to survive the
inhabitants have to do their part they
depend on cocoa cultivation for their
livelihoods and also on honey production
here they're being taught how to build
beehives and manage the bees the project
was initiated by the Frog
conservationists in the past
locals harvested honey in the wild with
fire but would burn down trees in the
process the new beekeeping system is
designed to protect the forest change is
afoot in your crop in another project
grown that was cleared to make way for
farmland is being replanted in just a
few years Gilbert Adam and his
organization have managed to enlist the
support of locals in protecting the
forest initially they didn't take his
work seriously and didn't see the point
of saving the Frog and its habitat but
now they've helped plan 15,000 seedlings
the forest is so vast so so vast and
there are so many places degraded see
how far we came into the chorus
and see the farms that have been it and
now the local people have agreed that
they will work with us we should do the
planting in the afrikanya farms so that
later the trees will take over
today the village of your chrome is
welcoming the community chief school
children are reciting poems to mark the
occasion of the celebration revolves
around the frogs and the Frog
conservationists Gilbert Adam is even
awarded a special honor popping up with
some pin defense
I swear allegiance to you nanyem to help
in the development of yo chrome that
made me the chief of the environment
environmental chief I've never heard of
an environmental chief in Ghana or even
West Africa so I may be the first
environmental chief across all of West
Africa and it's all because of nothing
else but frogs and the guys quick a frog
in particular the Frog has become a
symbol of the community's commitment to
protecting their environment
you
[Music]